going to the market can be held for
Nigerian women they are often touched
groped and insulted by men one woman has
launched market March a protest movement
that wants to stop the harassment most
of the media markets is succeeded in
Syria as traumatizing and refrain
experiences right from when doing
children and young girls even as a toe
something I expect when I'm going to the
market and I decided that something
needed to be done about it
every citizen happy rights birthday at
the first protest some men were
aggressive they insulted the women and
threw stones at them they really do not
think that we should resist them
touching us in very strong sense of
entitlement to any possibly do they
express whether they are pulling every
kind of stories whether its large people
who resisted where they slapped like
women resisted so it's visually the
problem is entitlement and expressing
that entitlement depending on market
value encounter and how ingrained is in
you Damilola says the March was a
success so many women are tired they're
frustrated about their position in
society and they want better and they're
taking matters into their own hands and
it's only going to get better from there
because it's like it has started the
momentum has begun and there is no going
back
you